nos piden sumar los números complejos 52
y 37 y muy bien para realizar esta suma
tenemos que apartar las partes reales y
las partes imaginarias y sumar por
separado las partes reales serían este 5
y este 3 y las partes imaginarias serían
este 2 y este menos 7 y entonces déjame
apartar las aquí voy a poner 5 3 que son
las partes reales y a eso tenemos que
sumar
tenemos que sumar las partes imaginarias
2 y menos 7 y este 53 es muy sencillo 5
3 es simplemente 8 lo voy a poner así 8
ahí tenemos un 8 y ahora para esta
segunda parte si tenemos 2 de algo y le
restamos 7 de algo nos queda menos 5
sólo que aquí casualmente ese algo es la
unidad imaginaria entonces dos y menos 7
y es igual a menos 5 y entonces nos
quedaría menos 5 y
y listo esta es la respuesta es 85 y que
una vez más es un número complejo porque
tiene su parte real y su parte
imaginaria